okay we will
call
this work session to order
and our
first bill is
establishing an electric school bus
program
mickey do we have an amendment on this
okay
right
is there anyone here that wants to
speak to us about
okay good morning thank you everyone my
name is kelly buchanan i'm director of
legislative and regulatory affairs for
clean energy new hampshire um and before
you today there's senate bill 417 which
is establishing a pilot program to
examine the use of electric school buses
in new hampshire
what i will say about this bill is that
it's it's pretty straightforward there
are some well-established guidelines in
the bill that determine the pilot
program and partnership with
whomever is applying that could be the
new hampshire utilities it could be a
municipality it could be a school
district
and then we also have
support from the department of energy as
well as any necessary intervention by
the public utilities commission
the other important thing to mention
about this bill is that it does not
establish any funding source from the
general fund it's simply taking
advantage of funds which are already
available to the state
so that would include the volkswagen
mitigation trust fund and those funds
are currently housed at the department
of environmental services who would play
a pivotal role in this pilot program as
well they really have the staff that are
well trained enough to envision how this
will function
and the other source of funding that
i'll mention is that the federal funding
from the bipartisan infrastructure bill
will be coming to new hampshire and
there's quite a lot of money on the
table and so this pilot program will
assist new hampshire in taking advantage
of that and i believe
the number is 17 million
and then there's another 2.5 to 5
billion in grant funding available so
it's quite a lot
and it simply enables new hampshire an
opportunity to participate in the
federal opportunities
of course with all the new hampshire
stakeholders at the table so if the
committee has any questions regarding
this piece of legislation i would be
thank you round chair
anytime representative
um
so um in this particular legislation
it's it's it's proposing five buses at a
cost of about a million and one point
four million dollars is that correct
that does sound correct to me i need to
take a look at the full bill again but
five buses does seem a small number but
i feel it's appropriate to start out
with such a number and follow up on that
certainly um
my my my other question is are these um
will there be students on these buses
will there be kids on the buses and
what's the how do we protect them from
these batteries bursting into flames
so i will say yes the intention is to
use these buses to transport students
however i would
point out to you that any bus that is
used would have to go through a rigorous
safety examination just the same as any
other bus any diesel bus that's used
another important consideration with
electric buses is not only are they
quieter for students
they're much healthier in terms of
internal air quality in a usual
diesel-fired bus you have high levels of
pollution that can cause asthma and
children and it's quite significant and
so
the comfort and the internal air quality
in these buses would be a large selling
point
are there other questions yes reps and
murray
thank you madam chair can you speak to
what the volkswagen money is being is it
being used now and what's available in
the volkswagen fund
so in terms of what's available in the
volkswagen fund there are a couple
different pots of money
the
department of environmental services
right now has an rfp out a request for
proposal for
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
and that's one part of the fund
i need to take a look and see what
exactly from this fund could be
delegated under the ev pilot
exactly and that would be a really
excellent question for becky ohler at
the department of environmental services
and i can
share her contact information with the
committee
i think there's
i'll use a phrase lots of money
there's quite a bit
we're talking millions yeah it's
multi-millions of dollars uh
from the volkswagen settlement
okay
represent petrie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um
batteries especially nicole when it's 20
below
loses current
how do they are they going to compensate
for that and does it have a is it going
to have to have a tow truck to
bring it around afterwards or what i
mean what's the deal
no so it's um you know when you're
driving an electric vehicle you it's the
same calculus as having a tank of gas
except we're dealing with different
units so you're thinking about charge on
a battery
so
these buses would be well equipped to
handle their routes and i know when
you're driving an ev you always have
that buffer consideration of exactly how
much range you have and so
it would be quite easy to calculate the
route of a school bus and determine
exactly how much of a charge the bus is
capable of and figure out that that mile
number um with the calculation used for
you know the lost efficiency that you do
see in extreme cold weather and that's
that's a real consideration
but usually we're able to plan around
those sorts of things
and the bus still works fine within its
range
are there further questions yes
representative
thank you madam chair have there been
any calculations done for school
districts um in terms of the cost saving
factor by moving toward electric
vehicles versus what they have now those
sometimes stinky vehicles
i don't have exact numbers in front of
me today i apologize but i will point
out for the committee that the
the oyster river school district as well
as nashua's regional planning commission
are both in active talks with producers
of electric school buses
and seeking to replace their fleets
so these buses often times over their
lifetime are much cheaper to maintain
when you have an ev it
it doesn't need an oil change
and what you're really looking at is
just tire replacement is your only
consistent maintenance especially with a
lot of miles traveled so
the cost savings would be quite enormous
in terms of maintenance
it's also less work for the school
district
they
are
rather
yes go ahead uh represent petrie thank
you uh do they have hybrid buses if do
you know
yeah i believe there are hybrid breasts
uh that's certainly an option out there
this pilot program however would be just
representative turkoff thank you madam
chair
did i hear you say oyster river and
nashua are already looking into
electric buses that's outside of this
pilot program they are examining that i
know this pilot program would be of
great assistance in terms of helping
other school districts that are perhaps
not
as fully prepared financially to take
advantage of this piece of technology
i'm thinking of more underserved areas
and rural areas that may truly benefit
in terms of improving their students
experience on the bus as well as their
air quality
but just to be clear they are doing it
outside of a pilot program they're doing
around their own volition they are
okay any any other questions okay uh
mickey handed out an amendment
um
and um
basically it replaces uh
for those of us that have been around
for a while
you know we have the infrastructure fund
the school infrastructure fund
and i believe in the last budget
we also
included in the infrastructure fund
the ability for schools to apply for
that for electric school buses
that fund
was trying to get repurposed
but it didn't make it and so i felt it
was important
let people know
that there is money in the
infrastructure fund to
support
electric school buses
i think the pilot program is good
i don't have a problem with that but i i
just wanted to
make sure that all funding
would be available
to them so
it's basically it's the last line
that funding shall not exclude a school
receiving
grants from the public school
infrastructure fund established in rsa
yeah i'm is is there anyone else out
there that wants to talk about electric
school buses
thank you everyone uh yeah i
new
good afternoon my name is john marasco
i'm the director of the division of
motor vehicles um i have not reviewed
this bill i have no i have not met you
before nice to meet you representative
congratulations on your new job thank
you so much i appreciate it it's uh just
it's been about two months now and i
know very thankful to be there and
working with a great team so great thank
you yeah and before i forget i just want
to personally pass on that
i was up at twin mountain
which of course is the bustling
dmv of the world
in case you didn't know that yes
but uh we got very good service up there
and uh we're very
pleased with um
with the work that the people up there
are doing so i'm so glad to hear that
thank you for sharing that and i know uh
holly and kim up there uh myself and
jeff oberdenk we had the opportunity to
go up there recently and they do a
wonderful job so
thank you representative let me just
make a comment excuse me i love twin
if you get tired of waiting in line any
place
you can probably drive to twin mountain
and back
in the time it will take you to
to get whatever you need done yeah at
one of the other dmvs
you heard this morning coast has uh 13
000 people and all 13 000 don't show up
at the same time
so just a little aside i'm sorry i i
shouldn't do that no that was wonderful
thank you for the positive feedback and
i'll make sure i pass that along to a
mountain thank you madam chair um
i have not read this bill and for that i
apologize i just came from another uh
committee meeting um but you asked if
anybody had any um any thoughts on
electric school buses i hear it's a
pilot program maybe you've already
studied this but i just want to bring it
to the committee's attention that we had
the benefit of a presentation by matthew
willmott he's a state fire marshal this
is probably about a month ago
i didn't know anything about ion lithium
batteries he gave quite a presentation
that was 45 minutes and it was very
neutral and fact based in academic and
i can tell you that for that
presentation
the
new hampshire automobile dealers
association was there some of the actual
dealers were there um i was there state
police was there there were several the
commissioner's office um
there were some things that were
highlighted during that presentation
that maybe this committee's already
looked at and addressed um but there
were there were some real safety
issues with those batteries that um most
of us in the room were not aware of so i
just wanted to highlight that bring it
to your attention if you thought it made
sense at one point i've already talked
to um fire marshall wilmot he's happy to
give the presentation at any time
anywhere to anybody
if that's something that would be of
value to the committee i just put that
out there and that's all i wanted to
offer
okay
uh
yeah maybe we can do that when when
we're in for
one of our interim study bills that we
have to do
that um
i'll get in touch with you and uh
and schedule it so that we can
hear what
what has to be said i'd be happy to do
that for you okay thank you thank you
representative
okay now i'm ready
um um i'd like to entertain a motion of
uh to pass for uh amendment number 2022
h
do i have a second
thank you
you want to say anything
um i believe that this amendment opens
up the possibility of various
uh federal funding as well as the public
school in infrastructure fund and i
think this is an area that
um it's it's new and i think it deserves
merit and investigation and this
provides that opportunity and to move
away from fossil fuel
okay thank you
anyone else
okay all those in favor please raise
one two three four five opposed
okay five to two the amendment passes
i will now entertain a motion for
otp a on
mary
i would move
um otpa
on um
senate bill
yes
all right um representative featuring no
representative votes now representative
no
representative
yes
no for them tomorrow
will you take care of that
okay thank you
okay
uh
we now move to
um
sb 401 with its 17 amendments
right
so i do have two from the department you
uh yeah well we'll we'll do both we'll
look at both of them and
make up our minds which one we want to
what
sure
oh
yeah
i've got
yes it's still here
one seven 1708
okay
that's still
in play
still still in play
okay
and then i have the one we heard this
morning
okay
i think we currently have
and i
no
you want to just take a break and go get
it
okay we'll just take a three-minute
recess while
representing lynn gets a copy of the
amendment
did you put in your book tom from this
morning
no go run some copies okay because
this one is by
i'm representative jack
oh okay
yeah that's good
okay
so mickey am i am i correct that we
currently have two amendments
on the table or
that we've talked about for
401 excluding these two new ones
yes we have the one that representative
jack provided and then we have the one
we had the non-germane public hearing
this morning
plus these two so in total now there's
yes
no i want the one with the holes oh
okay
okay does everybody have everything they
need
okay
uh
let's do 17
these are actually going to be done in
tandem okay
because what it what it is is it's
two different ways of allocating the
money
and the allocation
difference is
in the bridge program
so if i could have my friends from
transportation come in
and join us
and
a
uh
thing so you don't have to
flip through all the pages to
figure out where you are
so
um if you could
uh
kind of explain
the difference or what the two
amendments
are
looking to do or however you want to go
about it
yeah so um
we
were here at a work session last week
and we talked about the state aid bridge
program originally in the original
amendment
it was proposed that the 36 million go
through the state aid bridge program
and we had testified that going through
that program could take three to five
years for the money to be spent and the
committee had indicated
they wanted peace spent quicker get to
the municipalities quicker so
we went back and we looked at a couple
of different scenarios on how to
distribute the money um that um two back
to the municipalities
and so the first amendment looks at it
on a perspective
please do not look at the numbers yet
until we understand what they mean
because you're liable to gulp yes as
you're doing that okay so please
we'll go we'll get we'll get to the
numbers
so the first amendment 1749
um distributes the funds on a per capita
basis so it takes the the square footage
of the deck area that each town has
and then based on their population
calculates on a per capita basis
and then distributes that 36 million
based on the area per capita
to each of the municipalities so in this
situation
the lower the population generally
you're going to get more money
for your for the bridges
the second amendment
um takes the 36 million and distributed
um
similarly to the bloc grant aid formula
currently the block grant aid formula
currently that the 30 million dollars in
the bill and also in that bill
in section two
that is done fifty percent based on
population and fifty percent on the
roadway in each city and town this this
proposal in the second amendment would
take it fifty percent on population and
50 on the municipal deck area square
footage so it looks at um both of those
at a 50 percent and then distributes
distributes it more similarly to how
block grant aid
is distributed
so you can see that there can in the per
capita basis there can be some
inequities there
you know some of the larger towns um
with high populations maybe getting
small money the other the other way um
you know those larger towns and cities
are getting
you know a more proportional share to
the you know equivalent of the size of
their bridges and the number of bridges
and that type of thing
but
the department is more thinks it's more
equitable with option two um
and our approach
is it's similar to the block grant aid
distribution it's much easier to explain
that way that's how currently block
grant aid goes out to the cities and
towns and utilizing that methodology um
appears to be the more equitable
distribution
from our perspective but of course
that's up to the committee and what how
you would want to distribute it to the
cities and towns
maybe you could explain your numbers
here so that uh
so in the in the spreadsheet it's
alphabetical by the cities and towns um
we have bridge count
just as a reference but we've taken the
municipal deck area square footage of
those bridges
the population
is determined by the
office of planning and development so we
get that january 1st of each year
so we're using those population numbers
and then calculate that area per capita
and that distribution and then option
two
takes the population as a percentage of
the total
and the deck area as a pop as a
percentage of the total and then we take
50 percent
of each of those to get a total
distribution
and add those two together to get that
total distribution in the final column
okay are there any questions
go ahead representative murray
uh thanks thank you madam chair um how
do i know who owns what bridge because
you know i
it's helps me understand new castle has
two bridges but new castle is not here
at all so who owns the newcastle these
are municipal municipal bridges only so
i i apologize for not explaining that so
any state-owned bridges would not be
included here these are only municipally
owned bridges since the money is going
out and it was intended to go through
that state age bridge program which are
municipally owned thank you for clearing
you're welcome also turnpikes and
railroad bridges would not be listed
here
representative bucco thank you madam
chair i just um a question on
the
the second formula is is amendment
number
is that correct yep that's correct
did you have a question
person heath yes thank you madam chair
um so you recommend you no i don't know
if you recommend but you're you're um
saying that option two might be the most
efficient and
expeditious way to get these funds out
did i hear that correctly or am i just
jumping to that conclusion um
i i think potentially the most equitable
understandable the the size of the
bridges and the number of bridges in
those towns i think that this that
option
may be the most equitable so that would
mean accepting amendment one seven five
six h
and like i said it's similar to it's
it's pretty much the same formula as
what we're already doing block grant as
so it's something that's been tried and
true and we've been utilizing for many
go ahead
thank you madam chair um
do you take any account of the age of
the bridges in the in the towns because
if you've got new bridges let's say you
just did them i mean it's
it would doesn't make sense to uh we
have not taken any of that into account
um because of you know knowing that we
wanted to get the money out
expeditiously to to put in additional
formulas and considerations we felt
would hold up and not you know not be
able to get the money out as
expeditiously it would be a little more
complicated
um so we have not taken that into
account
if you remember they testified whenever
monday whatever friday but uh
there was a lot of extra money coming
into the um
state aid
bridge program
that's where you have a 20 match by the
towns
okay
so
the towns can either
fix or red listed bridges under this
program if they choose
or they can fix them under
the other program
so
you know it's uh
it'll be
up to each community to decide
what bridges they need to repair
and i don't think i have driven across
any
town-owned bridges any place in the
state that couldn't use some work
maybe
maybe otherwise
option one
thank you um
can you walk me through the narrative
looking at the numbers
um
i guess this is apropos smaller
community which may not have the same
tax base as a larger community
potentially so when i'm looking at
orford which is fairly small it appears
in option one there's three hundred and
forty thousand and an option two they go
down to seventy three thousand in
portsmouth which is considerably larger
um in option one it's 148
and
an option two is 741 000 difference of
600 i guess and i'm using thousand i
realize i'm
um
can you just talk me through both
stories about how how can i judge given
the big difference between these numbers
and the size of the communities which is
more equitable
um
it's it that's why i mean it's a policy
decision that um you know you can make
when you're looking at the number of
bridges in that deck area
orford has 13 bridges 8 000
who are you comparing it to
portsmouth
which has 15 bridges but 63 000
square feet of deck area so
you're talking about you know
four times as much deck area
um
and they're then they'd and they'd be
getting half of that amount of money so
i mean the bridges are going to cost the
same in each in each just in each
community so i guess it's a policy
decision whether you want more money to
go to the smaller communities or you
want it to be more equitable based on
the population and the deck area than
not you know the the size of these
bridges that these communities have to
repair and
maintain
i think when the department first um
came up with cats
sorry that's okay when the department
came up with the the first amendment um
we were looking to give relief to the
smaller towns but then when we looked at
the actual what the distribution would
be it seemed like it went too far over
in um
in favor of the smaller towns because
they didn't have the deck area but they
were raised by the low population
so
larger cities and towns weren't getting
money to meet the needs that the
amount of
bridge deck had
versus the smaller towns which didn't
have much and were getting a lot more
money so it just didn't seem equitable
from that perspective which is why we
okay
so
can i assume that we will just not
everybody is in favor of the other
methodology
okay
thank you
yeah i yeah i think so i was just going
to ask
i'm assuming this is a a nice easy
spreadsheet would it be
not we'll continue on what we're doing
today would it be possible get
and which 75 75 by dex 25 by population
thank you we'll get that to you later
today
okay
so could i have a motion on twenty zero
two to seventeen fifty six
so moved thank you
representative seconds
all those in favor of amendment
two zero two two
one seven five six please raise your
hand
okay
all right done
to
uh
1708.
okay
now in 1708
paragraph one
we just changed
this is the
normal distribution for roads
so that one
stays
okay
is the money for body-worn dashboard
cameras
hurry
where's the part that d.o.t wanted the
prohibited exception for dash cameras
please
because i i don't want i don't want to
okay
you've been in the mic we don't have any
amendments on section four at this time
okay
all right
so
is
paragraph two of
the jack amendment
does that replace paragraph two of the
yes okay so
this is
out the original bill is out and
this is in
so
if the division were to support
sections two and three uh the
appropriation with uh representative
jack's amendment you could just modify a
vote or if you want another piece of
paper i actually have an amendment
drafted
with just
us i assumed you were gonna do something
different with section one which we did
right so i do have another amendment
that just have representative jack
sections for two and three if you want
that
okay but then where do we have we don't
have four four we don't have an
amendment to because we're not
amending it so i'm gonna i'm gonna
eventually string these amendments so
we're gonna at least have two amendments
in all likelihood and then we're going
to discuss the amendment that we heard
this morning so with multiple amendments
being recommended i was going to string
it for one committee amendment section 4
is not addressed at any point in any of
these so that's why you're not seeing it
on the amendments okay but it will be
when we
i mean it would be in the underlying
bill as amended okay um
if it's the committee's preference to
see an amendment that replaces all with
and then you see it again i can
certainly draft it that way too i think
it would be less confusing okay
so when i do a
final it's not just me yeah it's we've
gotta we gotta get it through that other
yep group of people so when um when
we're completed our recommendations
we'll have multiple amendments in all
likelihood and division when i do string
it i'll do a replace all with and it
will still include section four okay
okay
is there anybody that's opposed to doing
that
that's a a lot easier i think okay
madam chair so
my understanding on 1708
um we would be
uh voting to either approve or
disapprove of this amendment absent
section one since we just
well mickey has something or i can just
kind of we can forget 1708 if you want
and have a replacement for gotcha yeah i
can do that very good all right
this is kind of like when uh when we're
finalizing the hb2 and
the budget and you get 12 000 pieces of
paper
no
this is just
this is taken out of the jack amendment
that's not in here
okay
so what would happen is you've you've
voted on on 1756
if you accepted this now you've taken
care of sections one two and three of
the bill four is unchanged and then it
would be up for a further amendment
which then we would discuss the
can i see if i i have that certainly
1756 replaces section one no okay yes
and then
1797 is gonna replace two and three
that's correct and it's four is going to
come back the way it was four is going
to come back in a new amendment
that includes sections one two three and
four
right
thank you
and whatever we decide on
dixville notch wrote
okay
so
all right
yeah could i have
uh
1797 17 thank you a second
second thank you all those in favor
aye all right
okay
now
is
seven zero three
which is
gulf links road
in
okay
well welcome there mr cass i haven't
we have all kinds of fun things going on
today
okay
are there
any questions
i have about a million but
well let's do the questions first
okay
uh mr cass thank you for coming because
i think you can answer my question
sure
for the record i'm uh william cass
assistant commissioner for the dod okay
good afternoon good afternoon
my question is
this road is currently a state road
correct correct correct okay
do we have any history as to how
it became a state road
the balsams don't say nowhere
okay i'm i'm i'm sure it goes
well back to the 1920s and 1930s before
route
26 was was built and
um
cold springs road
that goes around the
north side or the back side of
uh lake um gloriette where the balsams
is was was the state highway and down
over the hill and down over the dam
um and golf links road was was off that
and an abandoned portion that loops back
around to diamond pond road so i think
back in the back in the 20s that was the
roadway network up there before route 26
and stuff was built
when route 26 was built those roads just
continued to be classified as state
highways
they were never
abandoned or discontinued or or
or turned over
okay
it's it's apparent you
d.o.t does not want to use highway funds
to repair this
road
i would say that
there would have to be choices the uh in
the 10-year plan the funds are all
committed so
to
put those funds towards
something
some something else would have to um not
be done in order to do this
in order to do golf links road so
this amendment says you have to have the
funding and you have to have this and
you have to have that
before
you can proceed
so the the the legislature can previous
10-year plans had a condition in the
10-year plan about um you know the
funding toward the construction of golf
links road
okay
are there any other specific questions
that you have that
were discussed this morning
representative lynn
can i have to ask a question i i have um
i have gotten at least some suggestion
not at the hearing but from discussion
with another representative afterwards
that
there is some question or some feeling
perhaps in the north country that um
uh although
you know although this balsam's
development is very well intended and
people want people want it to happen
that
um
not much progress at all of it actually
happening
is uh
has occurred
and so i i i guess
um
you know that would normally be a
concern to me but as i understand this
proposal
the
the department wouldn't sort of be on
the hook so to speak for the money
unless all those other things actually
were did come together and so i mean is
that and you you've indicated that that
kind of thing has happened in the past
and other
so i mean does that provide sort of
sufficient protection
to the department that you're not going
to be
you're not going to be dumping out 4.1
million dollars if it turns out that mr
otton doesn't actually
get the development going
and in previous tenure plans there there
was that that that condition that uh the
funding for that project and the the
couldn't be spent until i think the
wording was commercial activities
commenced or something like that i
haven't seen that amendment i've heard
it discussed and i i think it is a
little more
uh specific in the and
and what needs to happen but i think
there's a fundamental discussion on on
whether it is the legislature's desire
uh
for
for the department to be to
with such caveats and protections to be
spending um
highway funds for this for this purpose
if that is the desire and we are
directed through the 10-year plan or
something we will do so i know there's
also been discussion about should should
some other other funding source that
would um right now the way the amendment
is is general funds oh okay okay that
would be
and i didn't know if that was your
question i didn't realize the amendment
was general funds yeah yeah so yes it
does offer those i i believe it does
offer those protections and
that's the desire to find to fund this
if the pro if the balsams project is
going forward
okay heath thank you madam chair is it
possible or feasible to use
this some of this infrastructure money
coming in
um for this purpose or is that not an
allowable expense
one of the one of the concerns i
apologize because the speakers in the
way the um
because of the classification of of road
it's a non-federal aid eligible piece of
highway so federal funds cannot be spent
okay are there any other questions for
mr
representative
thank you madam chair
um
i'm just uh
i know there's
there's
particular provisions of this amendment
that could be
um improved however this this project
has potential to be an um
an economic driver for the whole
northern half of the state not just
colebrook or the particular town but but
for the whole area
and uh
if this
putting this road in would be an
incentive to get the financing package
back together
i tend to support it
and that's i think what i'm going to do
are you all set with me no i have
another
[Laughter]
no this has nothing to do with this road
uh can you tell me or have someone call
me about when
[Music]
the
state property that was uh
taken for the bypass
is going to be available for sale
because everybody i have
i have discussed it with
they say well
nobody seems to know
and i know that you know we owe 20 how
much 90 million dollars
some exorbitant amount of money back to
the fed 20 28 28. yeah that's the right
number 28 million
that we owe back to the feds so you know
maybe the three million we could get for
the property would help
i i can get you a list i know
some of the sales are proceeding that
they're taking kind of parcel by parcel
depending on the most marketable and the
most interest um so i know we've had
some action around schema building
there's been some other isolated puzzles
that uh
um we've been working with um
uh it's been expressed interest from
coleman and others so we
we try to um
focus on the more marketable pieces of
of the bypass so um i can get you a
summary or something but
some are in the works some have already
gone forward so it is it is it is going
forward uh um trying to set market and
sell um
the remnant pieces of the conway bypass
okay yeah thank you you're welcome yeah
by the way when we do the budget
we'll have to put money in there we did
we didn't pay all that off did we
yo we're all well we paid it all off
last time well we it's not all paid off
we have a
sorry we have a plan a graduated plan
over three years to pay back federal
highway so it's not coming all at once
yeah
okay sorry for that that's okay kind of
off the wall question but i i would
appreciate that
and if someone wants a piece of property
they just let you know
that that'd be one way most of the
that aren't contiguous there are certain
parcels that that really only have value
of benefit to an immediate a butter
because the access and other things any
of the ones that are
marketable uh
we we typically um work through a
realtor to market and and
and sell so through either contacting us
or
through the realtor that's marketing the
property if somebody's interested they
can
get in touch that way okay
thank you
we'll be looking forward to seeing you
on may 9th
so when you're coming up for the
roundabout
at the police station
i think that was the date i wrote i
can't i can be i
i'm not sure oh i'm not
the department probably is i'm not sure
if i am oh okay that's fine
okay thank you thank you all right
oh
okay
so uh representative turcotte you had
thank you madam chair yes i would like
to
um
having heard
the this information today really for
the first time really and for me
creates as many questions as there are
answers
um
we learned that uh both the senate and
the house felt this road shouldn't be in
the 10-year plan
that was
pretty
some of the language in the bill i find
a little bit too vague financing must be
sufficient you know what's that mean
sufficient to what that's not very
specific
um
the other thing um when we calculate 4
million when you're talking about a 200
million dollar project that's about two
percent
of a project
i i find it
since the
senate in the house has already found
that
we shouldn't be fixing that road or
using our money in the 10-year plan i
find it um
i don't see a reason why we should be
doing that
um
if now just just a minute
if i could i understand yeah mr cass
would you mind explaining about roads
that
are
currently state roads but you want to
get rid of them
you
know and i and i think that
and i
i asked this question because i think it
will help you understand
okay maybe maybe not i i mean i
understand where you're coming from but
i i just want to make sure that
everybody knows
what what this is all about
so
so typically if we're going to um
abandon or or reclassify a road it's
called just discontinuing the road in
other words we divest ourselves and say
it has no more
uh use as part of the state highway
system so we discontinue it
um
typically
that discontinuance would go first to
the town
or in the case of dixville where there
isn't an incorporated town it would go
to the to the county
actually i think parts of the road are
in colebrook so between colebrook and
and coast county serving as the
administrative body for
dixville dixville notch um
they would have to determine whether it
is of interest to uh the
municipality if they wouldn't then then
they would also discontinue
any um
municipal interests in it and it would
then revert to the underlying property
owner
a lot of times when um when when we
either discontinue or class or
reclassify a road it's going to be a
class
4 road we're doing that currently and
we've done that currently in berlin a
section of 110
i think part of the um what we've
typically tried to do is
um
do some sort of maintenance upgrade so
it's turned over to the town in a
reasonable or serviceable condition
and back five or five five five
five or so years ago when this
golf links road project was um
first um
uh brokered or entered into the 10-year
plan that was kind of the philosophy
behind it that we would
we would
um upgrade um
up upgrade golf links road in order to
turn it over and get it off the state's
books
so that that that
principle
of
uh of uh
leaving a road in a serviceable
condition is is
um kind of what we typically try to do
if it is going to be that's typically if
it's going to be a municipal um
road or county road or county road right
okay
okay does that help i don't know if that
was your questions but
it's additional information that doesn't
make the point i was going to make but
so what i was continuing where thank you
uh my point where i was going with this
is um
there are many ways to skin the cat
um
i think uh attorneys at the d.o.t
or attorneys in the house or by doing
legislation i'm sure we could come up
with a way
uh
on a one-time basis that this
road could be transferred eventually to
the developer if that was the
um desire
the problem i have is spending taxpayers
monies for four million dollars to
upgrade a road that the developer
himself believes and don't get me wrong
i'm off for development and you you guys
fix up this road and you put some house
slots up there i'll come up and look one
maybe i'll even buy one but that when
you're developing a road like that four
million dollars where it represents less
than two percent of the total project
and in the end if it is developed
properly uh with house lots for second
homes and all that that money is going
to be recouped uh quite nicely so
i guess i'm just saying i think there
are other ways to do this without the
state first putting four million dollars
into the project then handing it over i
think there are other ways that we could
probably to find a way to hand
that prop that road over and let the
developer
be responsible for the development of it
are there further comments reps
underneath
my question is one um
simply to ask how much would it cost
to make that road ready to turn over
that's the four point that's the 4.1
million dollars thank you the estimated
cost i mean
you know it could be 2 million
or it could be
the state is only in this
we're only ever going to be responsible
for 4.1 no matter what happens with
inflation represent
oh
i just had one one other comment that
i've written down
and that is the state of the project
right now i mean it's
i mean i know everybody's excited about
it coming up and being developed but
it's still really at the infancy
so uh to be tossing another potential 4
at some roads i just
and i know there are some caveats in
there but i'm still
representative thank you commander chair
uh well this
project will let's
do the road that's gravel now
so in other words no but the whole road
will be taken over by the town or
whoever the county
if i understood what the
commissioner said
there is a portion of dirt road
in colebrook
that colebrook will do something
about
is that correct
we've already transferred it
commissioner gorman
the town of colebrook
worked with mr arton several years ago
because it's been going on for a while
the dirt road section that what i call
the right off them just before the
country club the town of colbert has
already worked with
developer autumn to turn that section of
road over to him okay so we we would be
looking for the state to to do as the
process i believe is
set up now that they would the state
would fix do its obligations fix up the
road and i believe the process will be
that they'll turn it over to the town of
colebrook in the county i think i can
speak as a selectmen and as a
commissioner we would then do the
process of turning it over to the
developer
that's that's how i see this happening
the way it's being proposed at the
moment okay um
so any other
questions
so you mentioned just a second you
mentioned this morning about a dirt road
in in
colebrook
is cold work going to
put that road
to
it was good enough for what they needed
and what they've been using for the last
few years i think part of the situation
with the reason we did it part of it as
quickly was the plans to put the real
estate in there they wanted to put side
roads they wanted to do things
differently so by us doing what we
needed to do to turn it over all right
they're still going to come in that end
of the golf course we'll still come into
the town of colebrook's road town road
okay and that the town road is dirt
there's part of it that there still will
be we own
this not on the balsam's property per se
what was on the balsam's property we got
it set to the way that the condition i
got all that i'm i'm i'm talking about
is colebrook planning to upgrade that
road
that's in colebrook
that's a possibility if if the traffic
increases
and so on and so forth
we'll see what the future brings if we
need to widen the road or
do better job of culverts we will do it
we we've if there's real estate
development and it is a town road we
will do our what is responsible okay
okay we're very very committed to this
the economics for us on this
is huge huge huge i can't say it enough
god
got it
is there anyone else
um i did speak to mr arton while you
guys were having lunch and i think mr
cat commissioner cass
back when these negotiations were done
in 14 and 15. as i understand it it was
part of a bigger situation
for example
the state had
owned the bolson's property garages for
their vehicles and a place for salt and
sand
and it's part of this whole thing the
state would turn over the road to the
county then to the developer the
developer would then continue to
maintain the road
and then
the developer
would and has actually given property to
the
state
at the bottom of the property now in
order to do their vehicle keep their
garage for their vehicles you're seeing
in the assault it was up on spur road
which was a little if you've been to the
ball since it was a little bit farther
up there he then deeded them property
down below as part of this bigger
situation i think there's a lot of
a lot of moving parts with i think with
with d.o.t
um
so
to your question the developer has
already given land to the state at no
charge
and where they are now housing
d.o.t vehicles salt and sand et cetera
and all we're looking for in this is
really just for the state to get the
road not up to the standards
that we have now but i think it's an
18-foot road
i think it's maybe an 18-foot road and
it's just getting it back i think now
you have to be 24 feet or 22 feet but
it's getting it back to just being being
surfaceable and unusable and when you
think about it
if the state decided to keep the road
they've got to go through private
property
i mean if they don't turn it over it's
comp the whole thing is really
complicated so i think it
yeah it's just a lot of moving parts so
i think this from the state's
perspective as mr otton said they're the
ones who said best thing to do was put
in the 10-year plan it makes sense they
took it out because they took it out
during covert nothing was moving and why
hold up money when you can do other
projects and now that covet hopefully is
over
and the financing looks like it's closer
to being in um
in place it made sense to look at it
through general funds if you have if you
have the money and
let me be clear if we've done our job
meaning the financing and the permit and
it's very clear in there we have to have
secured financing
i'd be happy and i did i misspeak did i
get that right
i might not right
there was there was an exchange
there was an exchange for the um
for the uh patrol shed that's there so
we have we have a building where uh we
have two bays where we keep a truck that
helps maintain the the notch so it's our
building but it is on the on the
balsam's property and
like i said the the historic
handshake agreements between why it's
still a state road and stuff
lingers to this day but
um
we did uh we didn't negotiate a
transaction with mr rotten in boston so
there was a piece of land on valley road
where we're going to be building a new
patrol shed
it was just awarded um
the bids were just open it's going to be
awarded that the next governor and
council in exchange for that uh we
negotiated an easement uh for for the
water line
that's through our um that that's coming
uh through our uh
patrol shed property down in arrow so it
wasn't so
that was a little bit separate but but
it is but it is
a lot of interrelated parts you are
correct yeah and and i think as mr ogden
said all of these various transactions
are separate but it was all part of an
overall negotiation and conversation
with d.o.t as to how we you know
we meet their needs meet our needs and
we get the state more money
from
bpt
mr tillerson certainly did some
yes go ahead
i just permission for mr cass
um
this amendment says that the department
of transportation will do the
construction so does that mean that this
road is going to be built up to current
standards
it's okay well i i just heard i'm gonna
follow him i just heard that it was just
gonna be
you know serviceable at the surface and
it's gonna need it's gonna need more
uh gra gravel and stone underneath so
that it's
so that it's come up comes up to
yeah we're
that's okay i'm sorry jumping jack
we had developed a project in 2016 that
we were ready to ready to bid um
and it called for i think reclaiming the
the pavement surface putting in some
drainage it wasn't complete
reconstruction of the road
and
uh when we say up this up the standards
it was the standards of i i believe miss
rosenberg said 18 i forget it was either
16 or 18 feet it it wasn't uh it was
more of a it was more of like a park
road typical than a than a state highway
type of typical but it did involve
um
a reclaimed surface and repaving with
some drainage additions to make it
functional that was the plan that we had
been prepared to bid and i believe that
would still be the plan that we would uh
put forward if it was funded
and that's what the cost estimate that
you have been referring to reflects
follow up
sure
um
so
will it will the road hold up under the
being under those conditions yes
okay
anything else
i'm sorry that we've had you jumping up
and down i
appreciate it
representative murray
thank you uh just a comment although i
appreciate my buddy's
considerations here i like to think of
this as an economic driver for the north
country it's and i don't like to think
of it just as a project pertaining to
the balsams but that it's a project that
will benefit all the north country and
it seems to me an appropriate thing that
we should be able to do to support the
north country
and that we're not on the hook for
anything unless all these benchmarks are
met
represent lynn i have to say if
if i looked at this purely from an
economic perspective it's hard to argue
with representative turcotte's uh uh
perspective on this uh
and i'm probably talking more from my
heart than my head but i do tend to
agree with representative murray that
this is an economic
development for the for the north
country in some sense and i think
you know hopefully this goes off i as i
said i've heard some
people express
doubts about whether it actually will
ever get off the ground further than it
has but
i you know the north country needs this
development and and i'm hoping it will
and to the extent this this can help it
and and i think there are sufficient
safeguards in in place so i'm going to
okay question how many people on the
okay
so
we want an invitation to play golf
on this on
assistant
yeah yes it's all recorded
[Laughter]
that's why i made the comment
but anyhow okay so um
could i have is there any other
discussion
okay
could i please have a motion
representative i'm sorry can i just make
one comment just to make sure that the
amendment does what the committee is
looking to do here
so on the uh of the appropriation on
roman four on line 23 of this amendment
i think the intent here is to cap this
at 4.1 million dollars of total costs
with it being an open warrant so not
necessarily appropriating 4.1 million
dollars
in any given year right
the only thing i just point out is
it does explicitly say construction
costs shall not exceed 4.1 million but
the open warrant seems to be for
construction costs and other project
expenses
so i think you'd want to just reconcile
those that terminology in that section
just so it's clear that it is a cap of
total costs at 4.1 million
okay so we need an amendment yeah i
think so which we're doing one anyways
for for all this so i'm just thinking
that's a pretty uh um a clerical thing i
can just clean up here okay
so what i would suggest is on line 23
have a say construction costs and other
project expenses shall not exceed 4.1
million just
okay
i
i agree
okay
so we'll
deal with this on tomorrow
there was nothing else i needed on this
no because we're getting a new amendment
you can do a committee vote on this and
even take a vote on me stringing the
three separate amendments together and
then i can provide it similar to how i
did with senate bill 420 yesterday if
that works for the committee
so does somebody want
okay thank you
and seconded by representing heath
okay well let's do the amendment first
okay
yeah okay
all those in favor of amendment two zero
two two
one seven zero three
with changes to
line
twenty five is that correct mickey line
23 i think we'd add construction costs
and other project costs right
there
yep
along those lines mickey um
construction costs and other project
expenses that
seems a little overly broad um could you
tighten that up to so it actually
applies to the road and not
other potential projects associated with
i know this
says to
project number five zero or four zero
five one eight but
when it says other project expenses
that's
we can make it we can say for the
project referred in this section we can
come up just so it's clear that it's
about it's confined to this project yeah
i assume there'd be some engineering
costs
i don't know what else there might be
but
okay six one
thank you
and now i'll take the uh
what do we want to call it mickey's
stringing together
sure and uh just because i want to
complicate things a little bit more for
you on 1756 that we adopted earlier the
36 million the proposal the department
walked us through
i just want to add a couple words in
there to make it clear that the half
that would go and be allocated based on
a municipality's uh population that that
is for municipalities with a municipal
bridge just so it's clear that it's
targeted for for municipalities that
actually do have a municipal loan bridge
okay so is there a oh i guess newcastle
didn't have any purchase
yeah
okay i just wanted to get that on the
record so when you do see the combined
amendment that that'll be uh
fixed so
what we're doing is that we're asking
lba
to put together
an amendment that combines all of these
individual amendments into one new
amendment
yep
okay
and that's strung along amendment um
that's going to replace the entire bill
that's correct
with
section 4 remaining as it is in the
underlying bill because we didn't amend
that in any way but i will present it
again in the bill so everyone knows what
the entire bill does yeah
connect so so that when we vote tomorrow
on the amendment
with we will have voted on the on the
the the complete bill
check okay all right
okay did you get that motion i did yes
okay
all right so um all those in favor of
the lba
preparing this amendment with
all of the sub-amendment amendments
please raise your hand
yeah no this is not a christmas tree
there's
no there's nothing in here that doesn't
deal with roads and bridges
and
body cameras or whatever
no
oh dear
okay thank you
we will now move to
sb
uh 442.
be yeah uh joe will you take over i need
to go find these my bills that i don't
seem to have here
which which one are you going for
somebody want to speak to uh
bill 442
state police no
anyone
good afternoon again cathy mulcahy
hampson my privilege to appear for you
but on behalf of the department of
transportation with me is mr john
corcoran who is the administrator for
the bureau of turnpikes
the turnpike system is maintained and
operated with toll revenue so there's a
great need to keep the toll collection
system fair
uniform and credible and that means when
someone chooses to use the turnpike
system they must pay for the toll or
they have to use an alternative
toll-free road
the purpose of senate bill 442 is to
close the loophole for total evaders
better toll
collection enforcement in dealing with
those who choose to use the turnpike
without paying the toll
has sent us on this road to to ask for
two enforcement changes first i'd like
to explain how the um ez pass system the
toll collection system works so you can
understand what we're asking for
the toll is supposed to be paid at the
time of use whether you use the cash
lane or you have an easy pass account
with the transponder it's paid at the
time of use
if you don't pay at the time of use
there is an option to go online and pay
within seven days you only have to pay
the toll there's no fee
if you don't pay within the seven days
we begin an invoicing process we send a
first invoice requesting payment of the
toll
plus a dollar fee if that's not paid in
30 days we send a second invoice asking
for payment of the toll plus a dollar
fifty fee
if that second invoice isn't paid in 30
days the matter escalates to a violation
and we send a third notice requesting
payment of the toll plus a 25 fee
so you're getting three notices to to
pay this toll if you haven't paid at the
time of use or within the first seven
days
when someone has ten or more violations
that is they've gotten those three
notices they know they have a violation
and when they have ten or more of those
violations they become eligible for dmv
hold
and that means they can't re-register
their vehicle when their birth month
rolls around
before anything happens to that person
when they have 10 or more violations
our folks at turnpike's reach out to
them say you have a significant number
of violations and we'd like to help you
clear those up
if they're not cleared up
we send their plate information to our
partners over at the department of
safety and department of safety issues a
letter another notice
and it says you have 30 days to clear up
your violations or you're in dmb hold
and you can't re-register your vehicle
a lot of people um are willing to clear
that up um before they get to dmv hold
some get nervous when they get the dmv
letter um but some people are in dmv
hold and they're waiting for their birth
month to roll around and then they find
out they can't register their vehicle
um the reason we're seeking
um
the two changes the first change would
be that instead of um
denial of re-registration privileges in
their birth month
the suspension of their registration
privilege would happen 30-day the 31st
day after they received the dmv notice
i have people who continue to violate
for 11 months after they're in dmv hold
and then they call up and they complain
why'd you let my total get so high
we don't have a magnet to take their car
off the road and move them we can't
prevent them from from not using the
road
if
their registration is suspended on day
that's an effective tool to keep them
off the road because that's an expensive
proposition to keep driving your car
when you're under suspension
the second change we're asking for
is because
we have some creative toll evaders in
the past they have when they go to
register their car and they can't they
would get a new plate and circumvent the
dmv whole process so we closed that
loophole
now what's been happening is they
transfer ownership of the vehicle so the
husband goes in to register his car he
can't
because he's in dmv hold so he transfers
the vehicle to his wife or an adult son
so we're in this the second part of this
bill we're asking that um someone in dmv
hold is prohibited from transferring
their vehicle
to a family member or someone else who
lives at the same address with them
which is likely going to be a
significant other or
relative or close friend
so in summary we're asking for these two
changes for more effective toll
collection the suspension of
registration privileges and the
prohibited prohibition on transfer of
the vehicle when they're in dmv hold
and we'd be happy to take any questions
and thank you mr channel
kathy thank you um
so
the dmv hold we already
you already have the authority to to
suspend the registration you're just
trying to move the dates up we moved the
data up right and so it
it happens sooner okay and then they're
not continuing to incur more violations
for the next you know nine months or 11
months however long it is until their
birth month occurs oh thank you when i
first looked at it it looked like it was
a new authority
it's it's similar authority but it's
more imminent it happens sooner
thank you
and thank you take my question how do
you catch them when you
negate their registration
if their
registration privileges are um suspended
then it would be a police officer or
state police that when they're driving
um they might get stopped for tail light
or another violation or the police
officer might run the plate for some
reason and they find out the
you know just a question i i
i see
i understand that the prohibition on um
transferring the registration to someone
with the same address but this also says
to a family member and how will you
how will you know if it's a family
member if you know first
the person has a different last name for
example we won't know so it's not a
catch-all but it is an improvement um
you know if a husband's transferring to
wife they can stop that um and if
they're if it's somebody with a
different last name but at the same
address they can stop that
if it's
you know we're not going to catch
everybody but this does limit it sure
thank you
i just want to put this out there i
think i know how i guess two things um
i worry
and i'm not very worried about it
but i do have to say i'm a little bit
worried about people who lose their
ability to get to work um and it can be
for a variety of reasons
um most of them probably not very good
but is there a way of negotiating with
you uh when they're in kind of this fix
and i totally agree they should not be
so far down the road here as it were
that they get into this much trouble but
can you just speak to that and the other
question i had um
you said you have a if you go through
the toll and you're you didn't pay that
there's
you have seven days in which you can go
online to do that
my legislative orange thing often just
never worked and so it you know alarms
are going off i never
knew what to do about that so how would
someone know
that they can go online and figure out
how to pay so there are signs that the
toll facilities that instruct you don't
have easy pass and it gives you you know
the address to go online to to pay
as a legislator you should not have to
go online to pay and we should get you a
new transponder that works properly no
it was fine and they told me i had to
put it in a better place and it did not
bother me but i'm thinking i'm probably
not the only one who would who would do
that but it was you know it just set off
in alarms and i was embarrassed
um and
to your first question um we work with
people all the time to um resolve the
fees um they incur a lot of fees if
they've been driving you know two or
three years without paying their tolls
they incur quite a lot of fees and
obviously you're not going to be able to
collect that at 25 and
john has a whole team over at turnpikes
that that work with these people to
resolve
yeah how much money do you lose every
year to non-payers or evaders
do you figure
so and that's a collection cost too yeah
um our collection costs are all paid for
and we come out
ahead of the collection costs so we're
not in the hole at all for collection
costs but we're hoping that these more
imminent steps will cut down on some of
the steps in collection and will be able
to collect sooner which adds to revenue
and
takes away some collection costs because
of time of our people
do you have a number that uh
what what you lose in
evaders
number of
money money wise
no we we as cassie mentioned
all our staff and all our work that we
do and the money we collect we're we
break even more above
so we don't lose any money sure you
don't lose any money
if i could
although you don't lose money the state
loses money
because you're not collecting the tolls
is that correct
if i mean if people are evading the
tolls
and you have twenty thousand dollars
that's evaded that's twenty thousand
dollars less
that comes into
the state
correct but i think we always stay ahead
of that collecting the tolls and the
fees so we
we're not losing money could we not be
spending as much on collection yes and
that's what we're hoping to do with with
these steps
we always collect all the talks yeah
make sure well you do if they pay if
they pay yes if they don't pay
then you don't collect them
in the fees that we collect off the you
know the whole process
we're still above yeah i got that so
you one more question you in the bill
that there's a set uh you've set out a
schedule of fines um
uh
or or authorized the commissioner i
guess to to make to to uh establish or
schedule fines and i guess my only
question is
am i understanding correctly that
if a person pays the fines
do they then get their registration back
or is there another fee that they have
to pay to get the registration back so
that's a good question and there's
sometimes confusion on this
this the statute that's being amended is
actually a department of safety statute
not a department of transportation
statute
so um because department of safety our
partners over there implement the dmv
bowl they're in charge of registration
and licenses and so they implement
we send the plate information over and
they
they implement the whole when it talks
about the director um in in um on line
it's referring to the director of dmv
and dmv has
fees that they impose to
reinstate
your registration privileges
um and i know from working with them we
the
violators have to pay the tolls and the
fees whatever they work out with us
if they're indeed being hold now they
have to go to dmv to to register their
vehicle and they have to pay
a fee to dmv to reinstate those
privileges fee is normally 50
would you like to do would you like to
uh
pass
senate bill 442
motion to uh sad as amended or just
in a second
representative heath
my show of hands uh all off no
no
you have to do a roll call
oh that's right okay
second yeah
yes
representative heath
representative murray yes representative
umber
yes
and i'm sure the vote is seven to zero
in favor thank you
thank you very much
so uh
len will you do the uh the blurb on this
the blurb the report
okay
excuse me lieutenant did you want to
talk you've been sitting here all this
time
oh okay anytime we're here
it seems like we're here
okay now we move to senate bill
346.
okay
all right
hey
you just had your freebie bill that's
right we
we had our freebie bill
yeah
and uh look at this we only have one
person
or phil
and uh
um
[Music]
since we now own
cultural natural resources
this is the first time that mr bryce has
been before our committee and we would
like to welcome you
to that and uh
i hope you have uh
enjoyed
listening to us
we're
we are very serious okay
um
why is everyone laughing
okay what this amendment does is the um
the bill itself appropriated the money
directly to the hampton beach area
commission
and we didn't think it was right not to
go through
a
um state agency
um unless we don't know but
that's that's what the amendment does
so uh mr bryce did you want to say
anything
uh
good afternoon phillip bryce director of
the division of parks and recreation in
dncr
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to this uh
the hampton beach area commission um
originally the bill was to have des do a
study
and we all agreed that it that they're
probably not the appropriate entity
and so the bill was uh
um amended to
um
go to the hampton beach area commission
which is a group of
uh folks uh you know the the town and
organizations in the community we have a
very
active um
partnership out at hampton
and the commission would ensure that
that connection to the community is made
because obviously any type of investment
like this would have an impact on the
community with fire
and with
police
because of the addition of this
structure
they are authorized in statute
to and were very involved of course in
the
uh development of the new 14 and a half
million dollar facility out there that
which which has been extraordinarily
successful
um
so uh we
we support them uh working on doing this
i'm in been in regular contact with
former uh senator stiles who regrets
that she can't be here she had to fly
out of state to help
take care of a friend and was hoping to
get back in time um for this but is is
on her way back from logan and suggested
that if you needed to
to um uh she could be available tomorrow
if you did want to follow up with her
but
um we're uh we're
um very supportive of the
uh amount of funding because we imagine
this will be a
a reasonably substantial investment that
requires thorough study
uh because of course the weather and um
the ocean is
is a uh uh it can be quite a quite a
force out there as we know firsthand
from our experience but we also
agree that a
a peer uh
would be a um
a wonderful attraction to the uh to the
seacoast and it's something that is not
currently there that you do have
other uh if it is possible to construct
uh you have in other other parts
of the eastern seaboard yeah i i don't
think any of us have any problem with
what
what what we're trying to accomplish we
flow
through
uh department of uh natural and cultural
resources or cultural natural resources
so
yeah
um
could we then do you know if we could
then allow the
um
you know part of it was we are really
flat out straight working on the
arpa funding that you all gave us
and this was a way of uh turning a
project over to
another entity to follow up on
um we're really kind of actually
stressed um quite a bit with trying to
to get that money uh contracted and and
spent
and i know um certainly uh former
senator stiles and john nyan also with
the chamber are committed to getting out
there and hire
uh hire somebody
uh and get something going so they can
put their you know their their feet on
the ground to get this done so we were
very
supportive of the commission
go ahead and doing this they do have
they do exist in statute we are on the
we are on
the um
uh
we are on the commission
and we
you know
worked with uh former senator styles
many years and very trust trusting that
she is going to be able to pull this off
i'm a little concerned whether or not we
would be able to get it done in the time
frame i don't i don't think this is
requiring you to do anything other than
to
accept the money and give it to the
hampton beach commission
that i mean that's right mickey that's
all there's no work required of you
it's all
just
it's just the matter of the money going
through a state agency
as opposed to directly to directly to
the commission correct
and is that are we all square that that
is
going to work in the in the
business process
no
can i ask there would be there would be
no reason to have to come back to the
gnc they've this is just a feasibility
study that we're giving them the
authority to do
we're giving them the money so that
hampton because we're not taking out
anything that's in the first paragraph
yes it's a straight pass-through of the
entire amount the natural cultural
resources won't take an administrative
fee from it so it's a they'll get the
it's it's general fund dollars correct
yes okay you know can i can i just ask
really a question of the chair i i
i have no problem with with it i guess
i'm just not quite
it sort of seems like
we're saying
and we're going to write two checks in
other words so the legislature's going
to write a check so to speak to to the
to the state agency and the state agency
is going to write a check to the town
what's why is it easier to just write a
check to the town it's because the state
doesn't
we would if we put in legislation that
representative lin would get a hundred
thousand dollars
okay
body some state agency
i search
somebody does if somebody has to write
the check and we're not we're not going
to write it ourselves i got it right
so if i may just uh clarify so it is
unusual um that we would appropriate
money to a non-state
entity so that when the bill came to us
the direct appropriation was to the
hampton beach area commission so we just
selected the most uh logical agency to
just have the funds flow through so in
the appropriation statement you would
see an appropriation for cultural and
natural resources for this purpose to
i don't think so i didn't hear the
question i'm sorry
no so section one of this bill is
unchanged by this amendment that still
requires the hampton beach area
commission to conduct the the
feasibility study there's no
responsibility here for the department
okay
um yes if if that is the appropriate way
to disperse these funds then um and then
we'll we'll uh
we'll confirm if there's any other
process but hopefully not the money can
just be
sent to the agency and then forward it
along to the commission
right
okay
do i have a motion on amendment
two zero two two one seven six seven so
moved
second okay
all those in favor
may i add my thanks
um for helping the help you did in
navigating tourism through covet along
the seacoast we had our zoo meetings
with senator sherman
and so i really appreciate you had a lot
to deal with with massachusetts on one
end and maine at the other and thank you
for helping to navigate tourism during
okay wait wait a minute one second
oh okay
so
sorry to
i'm fixing i'm trying to fix a lot of
things right now one that just jumped
out at me at this moment so
the content of the amendment is is fine
if you look at the bill title the way it
came over from the senate it says
requiring the department of
environmental services to conduct a
feasibility study that was the title of
this bill as introduced the senate
amended it to take des out of it however
when that amendment was drafted to do
that they never amended the bill title
and this amendment that i just gave you
here that we are good with also doesn't
so i
feel like we should probably clean up
the bill title so i can draft you i
think you can carry out your work and i
can have an amendment and i'll send it
to you tonight that is this exact
content just with a fixed bill title
i think you can just know that the
number is going to change but it's
yes the title and the number will change
but the the content of the amendment
will be unchanged you know did i have
that correct it was moved by
representative murray and seconded by
oh i'm sorry you trio doesn't matter all
right
all right uh so this is a motion of
octopass as amended on senate bill 346
fn uh representative petra
yes representative lin votes yes
representative turca yes representative
bucco yes representative heath
representative murray yes representative
umber yes
i'm sure the vote is seven to zero on
the affirmative okay thank you
all right does anybody want to jump
forward on uh
sure i'll do them okay
okay
all right
one second
all right so
i've got um
and
um
sb 417 i'll do that blurb as well
okay
um
i do
have a
request
that we
reconsider
which is dealing with
the um
it's advocate advocate okay
and
i could have a a second
okay and i'll i'll second it
to reconsider this and
hear it tomorrow morning at
10 o'clock
how long is that going to last all day
i know but we have to have our
we
we have to have all our stuff done
well let's see that's one two three four
five
yeah
for ten so you're gonna do it at ten
yeah because
because we've got that one
we've got um
396 right that we have 394 394. we could
do that we could do that now i believe
we recess to now with that one and i
have the amendment that i emailed last
night so you could
close that one out
it's
so this amendment
from our conversation yesterday on line
10 you'll see we added to clarify that
it's until their 22nd birthday
on line 16 we deleted the last sentence
relative to
the reference to rsa 171-a i believe it
was the developmental disability
services
and then down in the second paragraph
i added some
language that would take
that would allow for the department to
draw a warrant if the funds that we've
sure
it's still um
now we eliminated the section about the
adult services and the reason we did
remember there was a section about um
this action should negate
the ability to access the adult services
no we had we had struck that
right but i'm just asking why
i i think there was concern about the
amendment the first draft of the
amendment spoke to that the provisions
of such services uh
does not obviate adult developmental
disability service for which a student
over 21
may qualify i think there was a concern
of how it said may qualify
um
i'd have to that was the discussion from
yesterday to remember the specifics but
i remember that attorney's alan
and
i the lady's name escapes me now this
was their preference on this
rosenberger i think wasn't it
no it was uh
attorney's ellen because my concern is
that in representative in senator khan's
amendment he wanted to make sure that
this action
didn't
negate
the
capacity of the adult
service agency to get the services
and she talked to the two
they kind of should abut each other but
that
the reason we took it out
is because that is the normal process it
is okay and that's what it should be and
that's what it should be so we should we
don't address it right okay and and if
you recall they had a handwritten some
language that they said if you kept that
in consider this but if you take that
out we don't need this so that's that's
yeah
yes
the amendment that we're
considering is one seven seven zero
that's correct
so there was another one here
um did we do anything with this one
seven three one it's gone it's it's gone
714 is gone too 731 replaced 714 and now
770 is replacing 731.
so
i guess i want to
i just want to make sure
sure
my understanding of what we did
yesterday is a little bit different and
i just want to make sure that nobody
that that
nobody's sort of voting under a
misapprehension i thought that what
mr zelen and i thought her name was
rosenberg
no no rosenberg from the disabilities
rights
yeah just i thought that they both said
at the end
that they wanted to take out the
language which was taken out because
right now
there's right now i thought that the
department of education
i'm sorry dhhs was taking the position
that if somebody was getting special
dis demand developmental disability
services and the disabilities rights
center had a lawsuit in the process
going because of that and they were
concerned that we should just not say
anything in here
about that and so
that's why i think we took it out so i
mean i think that's the extent you were
thinking that they will get the services
i mean i think right now would only be
if the if the court says they should as
please turn your mic on
um the federal
idea legislation requires that
transition
um and for the services to begin to abut
so i i'm thinking that
what mickey said was we it already is
and so we just need to be silent on it
because it is what it's supposed to be
do anything else to
draw our attention to it or
no no i i'm i'm fine i'm fine on the
amendment i mean
to be candid i'm going to vote against
the bill but i am not but i'm fine on
the amendment
but i just want to make sure that we're
okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
you're thinking
okay
okay now we will call the roll
or
have a motion on
yep
all right um representatives peach
here's the third part it's just to
comply with the federal law that's
yes
representative
now representative
yes
yes i'm sure the vote is six to one in
favor of otp
okay
all right
no
i know i know first time
okay well
mickey
we also have senate bill 376 we could
probably close out
yeah i want to go through all these
bills so that i know
where i am
you know i don't know what i would do
okay
yep
they should consider putting that board
okay
yeah
police incidences involving citizens
affected with mental health
and the amendment
as we talked about um
in one
uh
the findings
number one is kind of a
general statement by the senate
and make this too
that's up to you if you want to pass a
bill that has a finding section in it or
not
i don't need it but i know the senate
tends to
love that sort of stuff so what do other
you're
referring to section one i
let's take it out
i know that'll be the that'll be the
committee of conference
that's to why they want the findings in
there
okay so um yeah
so what this is doing we had a little
long discussion about whether it should
be a separate board blah blah blah and
what we did here is
we didn't direct them to put it under
the law enforcement conduct review
committee
but
under the auspices
and similar to that established
in
the bill we passed last year about that
and it was just so that
all of it is in the same place even
though it's a different different thing
and the other thing that we did
was
we changed the appropriation by
for cit training
oh somebody asked me if we were gonna do
cit training
this afternoon and i said no
uh
it came right off
because of the um
the number of police departments that
need training
not every town has a police department
and um
i think that he said 48 had already been
trained
and
263 towns well
you know i can name five in my area that
albany
chatham
hills location
eaton
you know we've got all of those
oh this is a person that asked me about
i'm sorry
so um
i knew someone had asked me about it
okay so that was why we reduced it by
the hundred thousand
just
if it's done through contracting
it was like
12 000
okay
so
did you want to say anything on this are
all right
no we definitely support the cit
training
okay
is there anything
section
minus
finding is that what it is or yeah if
you look at the if you look at the bill
section one is findings yeah and this
no
oh i'm sorry
yeah
am i right
this says amends section four of the
bill by replacing
paragraph one
as follows so it's section four
do you
do you want a new amendment that does
strike the findings you can vote on that
and i can just draft it
okay so keep it
and then we're
deleting subparagraph
two
oh
and that was
because it's a repeat yeah if you look
at uh sub paragraph j on line 22 of the
bill you'll see that the president of
the new hampshire police association was
listed twice so he just deleted the
second reference
okay
yes
so it's staying in here um under duties
roman numeral two the list of all the
organizations is is stays
yup
it says the committee shall celest
in this case does shall mean every one
of them
or they shall solicit from the group
below
not that it was off
polly stevens i am the director of
public policy for nami new hampshire
and so what it would do is create a
committee which is made up of just
legislators
because we figured with a list of folks
that long that had a stake in this
that a commission would be way too
unwieldy so it's a committee
but what the legislation sets forth is
all of the entities
that the committee has to ask to come to
testify
obviously the committee can say no i
mean the organization could say no they
don't want to
but um and
i believe every single
organization on that list wanted to be
on that list
so
okay
you don't have to be on the committee
[Laughter]
i'm sure there'll be a reason for one of
us to be on that committee
okay
thank you
thank you paulie
all right
uh representative petrie's second
all in favor
opposed
6-0
we didn't lose anybody
okay
does it matter that the fiscal note
still says 1.2 million
do we care
they'll fix that
i mean
the fiscal note won't change until
okay
there is a fiscal note that shows
oh no that's different okay
i need a motion for sb
otpa
okay second
thank you
okay
all right this is a motion uh otpa on
senate bill 376 representative peter yes
president lynn votes yes representative
yes representative
yes representative yes representative
yes
okay
all right so
okay mickey let's the only one that we
haven't completed is 401
and 381
if yeah if we're gonna revisit 381 um
that one we would have to reconsider
and then we voted on that already yes so
okay we'll we'll do work with 381 and
then
401 um
that that's up to
the discretion of the of you if you're
wanting to
actually take a vote on the amendment
because there were a lot of moving parts
yeah i think that's in drafting now so
probably a tomorrow morning thing i'd
imagine i think we'll just wait on that
yep okay so i have
make sure i have everything if you would
346.
you got to do
yes i'll leave the mic okay
yep
494.
hold on
or 3.99 yeah sorry we just did that one
394.94
476.
three seven seven three three seven
yep
and then 401 and 381
one two three
that's fine with me
that give you enough time mickey
yeah i have
i'll have everything ready tonight i'll
send you the amendments that we
discussed today that are uh we'll get
those drafted
the only thing for tomorrow that could
possibly change by the sounds of it is
whatever we do with 381 so
an amendment it would i just have to
turn it around for three which shouldn't
be a problem but that's i think the only
okay
all right
11 o'clock
i know that you're going to get
yes
[Music]
so you want to give them guys a raise or
what
heads in the uh
there's three
you